today's question comes from jennifer in
pennsylvania i have a side hustle
and charge a fair price for my product
some of my customers are not financially
secure and i feel bad taking their money
if i lower my prices it wouldn't be
worth my time to do it
how can i stop feeling guilty for
selling to them so this is an
interesting question i hear that same
phrasing dave when i hear people talking
about
any type of sales they say i don't want
to take people's money well first of all
you're not
taking people's money they're giving it
to you because of the value of the
product or service you provide but the
other thing i would add to this is
if you're getting the wrong customer you
might need to look at your branding and
your marketing to get a customer
that can afford what you're doing
because you can't do it at a lower price
you're already charging a fair price
maybe yours there's something mixed up
in your messaging that you are
attracting customers that cannot pay
what you're charging and they're not a
good fit for you then so you change your
messaging to get a different customer
that can afford
the price that you're charging which is
fair to you the the what we tell people
all the time david
the price that you charge should be fair
to you as the business owner
and fair to the customer needs to be
fair both ways but
this idea that you're responsible for
their money management you're not
but you may want to look at your
marketing if you're if you're getting a
lot of pushback that you know these are
not the right customers
there's a not a right fit what would you
add yeah
or what are you reading into that
i don't i i can't tell all that's going
on here
honestly i'm just sitting here but you
know some of my customers
are not financially secure and i feel
bad taking their money
uh the grocery store where they buy food
does not feel bad
yeah taking their money for the food and
they didn't rip them off
now if you're ripping them off yes
that's another thing right
okay you're not oppressing the poor i
mean if you're a payday lender
you're screwing the poor right okay
that's that's not good that's
horrible yes horrible business if that's
what you're doing then
don't do that you know but don't and
don't overcharge them
don't oppress the poor if somebody's not
i don't know what you mean by not
financially secure most americans aren't
financially secure
just about everybody yeah you know uh
and so
you know i own a pizza place i don't but
i mean if you own a pizza place you only
sell to financially secure people you
may not sell many pizzas right
right so but you it's not your job to be
their
mommy and their daddy and their nanny
that's right uh and so
your job to sell pizzas right and your
job sell groceries
and whatever it is you do but again now
the other thing you can do
is out of your profits when you set your
price at a good fair price
you can turn back around and say i'm
going to donate a certain percentage of
our
goods or our services to someone
yeah that is truly in need right and
that generous heart is fine
but to adopt your whole business or to
build your whole business model
around other people's decisions you
can't do that
it's impossible to anticipate that yeah
they're not responsible for it
this is the ramsay show